Entropy has a mathematical formula.
Let me give it to you now.
The formula is -Pi log2(Pi).
Let's unpack this.
Pi is the fraction of examples that are in a given class, class i.
And then, you sum over all the classes that are available.
In the next few videos,
I'll give you lots of hands on experience with performing entropy calculations.
But first, let me give you just a little bit of intuition.
As you can see from this definition,
entropy is basically the opposite of the purity.
So, in one extreme you can have all the examples be of the same class.
In that case, the entropy will be 0.
In the other extreme,
you can have the examples be evenly split between all the available classes.
In that case,
entropy will take on it's mathematically maximal value which is 1.0.